hey guys this is just a quick improvised
tutorial on some tips and tricks in
planet coaster it's a little bit
unorganized but it was requested and I
promised and it might give some good
insight into what I'm doing in my
regular episodes except at 12 times the
speed so it might not be as easy to
catch so first in any building you built
you're limited to the grid which is the
size of a basic wall as you can see but
you can actually make the grid smaller
by placing a sandstone curved column and
just removing it directly afterwards and
now you'll just be able to place on
quarter tile grids likewise if you just
start building a building you're only be
able to raise it in full wall height
increments but if you very quickly place
one of these flat roofs and remove it
shortly afterwards
you'll actually be able to instantly
place everything in very small
increments like this you can also put
walls at different angles within one
building by actually exploiting the
duplication in the game for instance if
you place down one wall like this then
completely exit out of the building then
you click on the wall and press control
D to duplicate it then you'll be able to
place another one and freely rotate it's
completely independent from the other
wall which you placed and each time you
place it you'll be given a new one and
if you're done with this you just right
click and leave out of that and if you
click on this this is one building and
with this trick you can actually make
some nice curbs and fences for paths for
instance placing down a sandstone flat
roof edge exiting out of that using ctrl
D to duplicate it and you'll be able to
just place it alongside the path like
this actually get rid of rotations now
makes it a little bit easier and make
some custom curves these by the way are
some really good objects to use for
curbs and fences and if you want to go
the extra mile you can use the wooden
balconies and connect them to these
curves in such a way that you can make a
little wooden railing be sure to sink
them deep enough into the ground though
just like that using this you can also
put some matches on your path just
duplicate this wooden roof piece and put
it wherever you like these three
chimneys over here can be used for a lot
of things that aren't actually chimneys
lower them into a roof and line them up
with windows to make them look like
dormers use them as the bottoms or tops
of pillows or stack them to make some
Asian lanterns
or posts for fences and balustrade
now when making cross beams or details
and buildings it's really important to
have good control of the control and the
shift-key and basically what it means is
that shift is going to sink in objects
into anything which you hold your mouse
on and control is going to move you that
objects vertically or horizontally in
relation to the object on which you're
holding your mouse so take for instance
I would take this balcony if I point the
mouse towards this wall and you shift I
can sink it into the wall or bring it
out from it and if I press control I can
move it up or down or left or right now
the same goes for any other surface so
if it's an inclined surface it's going
to sink into that in an incline now you
can use this trick to very precisely
move objects so say for instance I'm on
this roof right now
I would sink it into the roof to bring
it right there and to move it here I
would have to use control but now my
mouse is pointed to what the wall so if
I press shift now I can move it into the
same direction as I just now did so
always keep in mind what your mouse is
pointing at and use ctrl + shift to your
advantage to move any object anywhere
the easiest way to make horizontal
crossbeams is to use the wood platform
overhang which we use for a bench
earlier and just sink it into a wall
just like that with the narrow thing
sticking out alternatively if you want
to have a thicker beam you just spin it
around and put it in there and you have
a very thick cross beam and if you want
to have a diagonal cross beam you take
the wood balcony put it on a roof like
this and bring it out to the front here
using control then using shift then
using control again you can sink it down
if your mouse is on the walls and by
using shift from this point onward you
can sink it into the wall
now since an object will rotate itself
based on the surface which are placing
it on you can actually place some mock
objects to get a specific rotation which
you need for instance if I want to make
a less steep cross beam you can place a
roof like this and then very similar to
how I just did it place a balcony on it
and sink it into this building bring it
out using shifts and maybe just slightly
change that placement like that and
there you go you can also use this to
make corner stones for your buildings
if you take the roof modeling stone
flats and put it on the opposite surface
of where you want to put the cornerstone
and then sink it into it and drag it
down you can actually make a row of
cornerstones one thing to keep in mind
when you're doing this though is to make
sure at all times to keep your cursor
pointed at the wall on which you
originally place the molding because if
you don't and you accidentally click on
the grass for instance your thing will
rotate and you'll have to place it all
over again similar to this you can also
make some straight concrete posts and
any building by placing it on the
opposite side sinking it into the wall
like this and then simply stack it this
is also a good example of how the
rotation of an object also determines on
the place within that object that you
may have your mouse over for instance if
I would click right now and place this
building while having my mouse over this
wall the thing would instantly rotate
and be useless but if I keep the cursor
exactly on that face of the object which
which faces the same direction as where
I originally place the object I can
still place it and it won't be doing
anything weird when it comes to
rotations Errol's make some pretty good
planters just sink them into a path just
like this until only a small Ridge is
left and then place whatever tree you
want to place on it I'd like to place a
Cypress on it and you have some small
planters this game doesn't offer any
ferns so far but you can actually sink a
palm into the ground a little bit and
make it look like quite a fern and this
is how it looks lowering the bushes
allows you to make some sweet flowerbeds
even with this yellow maple tree there
we go and the same goes for this one
really just make sure it's low enough
for the flowers to still be there and
there you go so yeah that's all for this
video I might make some actual series
and in that tutorials at some point in
the future but since it's just very
early for me as well and the game is
still really much in alpha I figured
this might be a bit more helpful for
people especially those who don't have a
lot of experience in the game yet or
room or we're wondering about a couple
of things in my time lapses
you